CBS News has learned US officials
believe al-qaeda's chief bomb maker was
killed officials are confident ibrahim
al Asiri was killed last year in
American drone in an American drone
strike in Yemen
according to reports he was hit with his
associates in the governance of mreb
David Martin is at the Pentagon David
good morning good morning the US has
long considered the al Qaeda branch in
Yemen as its most dangerous affiliate in
part because of our series expertise in
explosives he has escaped death from
drone strikes many times but this time
US and knew many officials are confident
he is dead ibrahim al Asiri was known as
a master bomb maker and after Osama bin
Laden was killed he might well have been
the single most dangerous terrorist in
the world this is the most significant
removal of a terrorist from the
battlefield since bin Laden he was that
important in 2009 as Siri design the
underwear bomb which nearly took down a
u.s. airliner over Detroit on Christmas
Day no one was killed because the
suspect wearing the bomb failed to
properly detonate the device a year
later the Saudi Borna Seri nearly pulled
off another attack by hiding explosives
in printer cartridges being shipped on
cargo planes to the United States the
devices got through airport security in
the United Kingdom and were only
discovered because of a last-minute tip
probably the most sophisticated
terrorist bomb maker on the planet
surgically implanting explosives inside
of human bodies more recently a Siri was
believed to be working on a bomb that
could be hidden in laptops and mobile
devices prompting the TSA to ban such
items on some flights to the US there's
gonna test the excitement of a good
chunk of what you have to take out of
your bag and what has to be screened is
because of a Siri and his capabilities
putting explosives in very difficult to
find places a Syria has not been heard
or seen since that drone strike last
year he
been removed from the battlefield but
officials fear he has trained others in
his deadly skill of putting bombs and
hard-to-find places
Nora big win for the US military David
thank you